woman trying to bury her husband who  died in a car crash last week is getting  some help tonight charles wade jr a  vietnam veteran was crossing tropicana  near torrey pines when he was hit his  wife anita was having a tough time  coming up with the two thousand dollars  needed for the funeral down payment  after sharing her story neil sachman  from nevada coin mart came forward  we would like to present you  [Applause]  with a check  thank you so much  and again that's neil sac mary anita  says this will help her start the  process coming up at six o'clock joe  moeller shows us why sac mary shares  why he was compelled to help out a bit  here